Tesla recalls over 362
000 Vehicles says experimental
self-driving software may cause crashes
the national highway Transportation
safety administration posted a recall
notice which says Tesla's full
self-driving beta may allow the vehicle
to act unsafe around intersections can
confirm
I'm a big fan I like Tesla I think Elon
does good work but yo these cars they
nearly got me killed what happened they
slammed their brakes on randomly no way
randomly dude it is you were like sort
of vaguely driving the car and then the
brakes slammed on you'll be driving and
you'll turn on so on like the model 3
you you flicked the this the stick up
twice and then it changes from cruise
control to auto drive and you activate
full self-driving and then the model S
has like a button you press or something
I'm driving and it's on the highway and
then there's a merger there's an on-ramp
a normal sane human keeps driving the
driver who's merging on knows you have
the right of way and to yield slows down
allowing you to go forward
full self-driving slams its brakes on
which is would cause a would cause an
accident I think there was a video of
that that happened in San Francisco yeah
it slammed its brakes on on the on the
bridge and then all these cars piled up
and people got hurt oh my God it's
happened to me enough times to where
you know
um like I've tweeted at Elon like hey
man like this is a serious problem like
I don't I don't I don't even know if we
should use it no don't use it anymore
because and it's only happened I think
like three times out of out of the 500
or more that we've driven it can you use
it without the auto drive oh yeah of
course it did the thing anyway I'm just
saying when you turn on Auto Drive
you'll be driving and a couple things
happen one whenever there's a flashing
yellow light it stops doing this it
thinks it's a real street light and
it'll show a street light on the display
and then slam it'll start it rapidly
decelerates from 65 down to like 35 very
quickly and you've got to tap the
accelerator to get to stop so if you
don't expect this but there was there
that we've had moments where it slams
the brakes on and we've lunge forward
like what the Yeah because if you're
turning the wheel when it slams it on
that's a skidding Hazard like that's
yeah that's not even the scariest part
of a lot of this stuff too because
there's like there was a video I saw the
other day where it was like it will run
it will like go around uh buses that had
their have the light out so it's not
picking up all the people it's like
there's a lot of other stuff other than
that that they're finding with these
self-drivers that's illegal to pass a
bus when yeah let me so so basically the
Elon Musk is saying recall is a strong
term for we're updating the vehicles
overnight but they mentioned this too
the agency warned the system May respond
insufficiently to changes in posted
speed limits or not adequately account
for the driver's adjustment of the
vehicle's speed to exceed posted speed
limits also this happens a lot and it's
really annoying
Auto Drive is supposed to adjust the
speed limit for the posted speed limit
when you're driving and you drive past
and it says like 35 it will drop down to
35. several times when I've been driving
it won't and so I have auto drive on and
then it drives past 35 and it adjusts I
can see it on the display and then it
just keeps going 65 and I'm like okay
I'm sitting here paying attention so
I'll push the brakes down but that is
terrifying that it won't yeah that's
really scary is it is it is it looking
to see like what the actual sign says
because I know like in my neighborhood I
live in a private drive and apparently
Google has our private Drive listed at
like 35 miles an hour it's like a 15
mile an hour Zone and so that's one
reason why we think maybe people are
speeding through our neighborhood is
because the closing speed is wrong and
so if if
um
if the Tesla is going off of like what
Google says then that might be one of
the reasons you'll be driving
you will see in the distance the speed
limit 35 as you get close to it it
appears on the car's display and then it
changes max speed limit to 35 but
doesn't press the brakes down it just
keeps going twice the speed limit I will
say as someone who only I mean I failed
my driving test three times before I was
for various reasons but I recently got
my license a couple of years ago I got a
car and I really like just being in
control of my car I kind of wish I knew
how to drive manual so that I could be
even more control of the vehicle that I
am driving and you can feel the weight
like you're driving you know someone who
never drove before you can feel the
weight of this massive vehicle that
you're in control of you know driving
sticks not that hard it's just annoying
it's like what's the point some people
like it you have the clutch it depends
on what kind of car you're driving like
if you're driving a nice sports car it's
fun to drive but yeah I got it I gotta I
got a manual car I've driven I used to
drive stick all the time and it's just
so much easier and safer in my opinion
not to for the average person like you
know look you're driving stick shift and
you're on a steep hill and you got
people behind you and then they get real
close to your ass and you're like dude I
can't move if I if I take my foot off
the brick I'm rolling backwards and you
can't do anything you're like
this is part of the reason why it took
me so long to get my license and why I
never drove manual because my mom was
teaching me how to drive a car she had a
manual transmission car she pulled
halfway up the hill put the parking
brake on put me in the car and was like
okay now go and I was like what I'd just
be like sure I'm gonna grind your gears
and destroy your clutch but I'll do it I
learned you destroy the emergency brake
because that's your break to keep you
from Rolling backwards you work the
brake as you're pulling forward oh is
that we've never done that before that's
a good idea
I learned stick shift when I was 16 or
17 and my parents were going out of town
and they were taking the automatic so
they're like well I took it to work I
had to keep the stick shift and I I
shredded my Dad's Transmission
it was uh I learned though I learned
just a lot of grinding trying to get
well electric cars don't have
transmission so they don't have
Transmissions at all they just go yeah
it's an electric motor the wheels are
just electric motors they spin when
there's a charge there you go it's a
feature everybody except the
self-driving stuff but they're putting
self-driving at everything
so even even the Honda we have a uh I
have a Honda and it uh it has Lane
correction or whatever it's called Lane
assist like any of this I don't want my
I don't want my washing machine talking
to me I don't want my car driving for me
you're gonna be in your car you're gonna
be one of these people who's just like
what's going on what is everybody in a
pod you're gonna be 70. yeah you're
gonna get your first robocar and you're
gonna be like I finally decided to do it
leave me alone you're gonna get in your
car you're gonna turn it on and go
robocar take me to the grocery store and
it's gonna go kill me and then you're
gonna be halfway there and it goes by
the way are you Libby Emmons
editor-in-chief of the post millennial
and you go yes and it goes okay
I've been looking for you you mean I
never get to retire either like I'm
gonna be 70 with no teeth
and having my same job that is the most
that's more depressed like I hope the
car killed it what I don't like about
self-driving maybe Elon can convince me
of this when I talk to him but it when
we train yeah trains have tracks so
they're self their self you don't need
someone holding a steering wheel planes
don't have other planes flying by them
80 feet away they do these days 12 000
miles an hour whatever the hell so cars
the solution of our Air 2 000 pound
Vehicles flying past each other at 50
miles an hour relative to each other uh
how is that's even remotely safe to
leave in the hands of a computer with
your eyes off the road or like like you
just are you seriously considering
people aren't going to go to sleep
behind the wheel in that situation or
turn around and talk to people well hold
on hold on I've fallen as fallen asleep
while driving before no way that's awful
I think aren't you terrified it happened
to me once I think most people have
experienced that I almost I used to
apply it too I used to work they make me
work mandatory over time when you work
at the airport so I I have to do a
double shift I get it I get there I have
to I have to wake up at 3 30 in the
morning I to drive an hour to get to
work to get there on time otherwise they
fire you then they're like okay you
gotta double shift today because you
need the money then they say whoopsie
it's mandatory overtime I don't think
they can do Mando if you've done a
double though but you'll end up being
it'll be it'll be 10 o'clock you'll be
leaving and you'll be driving home and
then you're just like whoa crap I fall
asleep for a second that's that's scary
scary yeah and I think a lot of people
have experienced that long day of work
getting tied behind the wheel but with
at least with the robocar you turn it on
if you fall asleep you wake up like oh
yeah you know ideally at the at that's
at an emergency backup situation but to
entice people to use it test it out is
like what in the hell are you doing what
I mean they are huge amounts of metal
flying like well super speed did you see
that story of the guy tried to kill his
family and the Tesla I sure did drove it
off a cliff and they all survived yeah
and they were like he was trying to kill
us Tesla was just very safe they're
well-built machines yeah and so it
rolled down a hill and they were like
we're all fine the Tesla trucks look
super Terminator and creepy yeah and you
sit in the middle really yeah so you're
just like one guy in the middle you
can't have anybody else in there and
there's like panels to your side full
protoss you'll be driving with your mind
pretty soon oh my goodness no you won't
you'll be telling the machine take me to
Wendy's the machine will be driving with
its mind we just have to hope it's not
Sydney from Bing chat
is the Tesla truck coming out though
because now everybody's coming out with
electronic like trucks and stuff like
Jeep just had to add in the Super Bowl
for their new off-road
you know electric jeep looking for a
date of the official release uh rumored
release date of the Tesla truck
I don't see anything off the top I know
they have a sports car that's supposed
to be coming out won't begin mass
production until late 2023
this is according to tomsguide.com
so late 23 we'll start to see the
production early production in the
middle of the year of 2023. uh so maybe
three or four months they're going to
start early production I mean I like the
idea of electric trucks or whatever
these can't go that far so I think they
were they were saying that it can only
go like 100 miles on a full load or
something like that I think the Tesla
truck was saying you almost ain't gonna
go like 500 but then imagine that you
got to stop and charge it for how long
yeah right there was also I saw this uh
this guy was trying to charge his I
don't know some giant truck thing and it
was going to take a week
to charge fully jeez well even like the
Jeep when I saw the ad for the Jeep I
was like this kind of seems pointless
you go off-roading and then there's
nowhere to charge your vehicle and then
I'm just kind of stuck right then what
do you do thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time